the Earth spins faster along the Equator
so the impact of zero gravity would be
felt hardest there
at the equator you could experience
winds almost six times stronger than the
ones produced by Hurricane Katrina
that means that in just five seconds you
could be blown as far as 2.3 kilometers
in any direction
and not just you there will be plenty of
people objects and animals to look out
for not to mention trees soil and
mid-air floods from the world's ponds
lakes rivers and oceans
at the same time the gases in the
atmosphere would drift out into space
not only are we now losing huge amounts
of oxygen but the sudden and sharp drop
in air pressure would instantly shatter
everyone's inner ears
and then there's the planet itself which
is literally held together by gravity